[Musica]
o l'altro giorno ero a scuola lezione
all'aperto loro intorno a me ben
distanziati naturalmente io che leggo un
libro
e a un certo punto non so perché mi
viene da spiegare loro la differenza fra
senso letterale e senso figurato
provateci voi a una seconda media a
spiegare che cos'è il senso figurato
sapendo che senso figurato nel
dizionario e abbreviato così li dovete
mettere in conto almeno un minuto un
minuto e mezzo di battutine risatine
occhiatine el attenzione se ne va
passa quel minuto minuto e mezzo
l'ormone cala un attimo la sua e provo a
prenderla un po alla lontana cioè a dire
loro che letterale e figurato sono un po
come due contrari
no e allora chiedo un ragazzo di dirmi
il contrario di alto basso prof
bravo grazie poi vado da una ragazza e
le chiedo con al contrario di bello e
lei brutto prof
brava grazie e poi vado da lui
il ragazzino quello timidino quello
pallidino quello che cerca di
nascondersi sempre perché se compagni lo
prendono sempre in giro perché ogni
volta che prova a dare una risposta non
ne azzecca una
mai proprio e allora un po anche per
tirarlo su di morale cosa faccia gli
faccio una bella domanda facile così la
risposta è scontata è e gli chiedo dai
dimmi il contrario di luce e lui così
pupilla dilatata come se gli avessi
appena chiesto la formula della fusione
fredda non sa dare una risposta
terrorizzato poi e io lo guardo il
controllo di luce e anche i suoi
compagni si girano da il contrario di
luce
e lui dopo dieci interminabili secondi
fermo lì sotto appunto al suo momento di
eva ce l'ha fatta di luce ma è lui
spenta come spenta come spenta compagni
giù a ridere naturalmente no e lo
ammetto lo ammetto che anche a me è
venuto da sorridere spenta la luce
spenta dai però è durato un secondo
perché poi ho avuto come un flash
un'immagine che mi ha fatto fermare e
dire a tutta la classe fermi fermi fermi
il vostro compagno via appena dimostrato
che è molto molto intelligente
anzi vi dirò di più segnatevela
ricordatevela questa lui un giorno farà
qualcosa di grande scommettiamo che cosa
stata quell'immagine quella cosa
bene il mio intervento qua oggi con voi
si intitola elogio del fuori tema va
bene e quindi io per perfetta coerenza
col titolo che ho scelto adesso vi parlo
di fiumi
sì perché dovete sapere che i fiumi non
fanno così sorgente foce non vanno
dritti ma fanno tutti così fanno i
meandri torna indietro vanno avanti no
addirittura c'è stato un professore di
cambridge nel 1987 hans heinrich sto lum
che si è fissato voleva trovare la
formula matematica per capire la
lunghezza dei fiumi e la trovò scoprì
che tutti i fiumi del mondo allungano la
strada dalle 2 alle 3,14 volte il loro
percorso quello dritto il pi greco 3,3
sempre fuori accidenti prendiamo
prendiamo che ne so il nilo guardatelo
che bello il nilo e meraviglioso perché
parte che va abbastanza dritto e ci
sembra che abbia un'idea abbastanza
chiara di dove vuole andare perché al il
mal rosso è un attimo deve solo superare
la croccolo etiopico lì e lo supera bene
ma un certo punto guardatelo cosa fa il
nilo si ferma si blocca e dice
no io voglio andare nell oceano
atlantico e parte dritto verso l'oceano
atlantico che a 6.000 chilometri da lì
aveva il mar rosso lì a poche centinaia
di chilometri non lui torna indietro che
un po come quando sai e quei momenti no
che bici basta io domani mollo tutto e
vado a vendere pantofole per cani uguale
e il nilo però lo fa è il giorno dopo va
a vendere pantofole per cani guardate
come torna indietro la punta dritto
ormai era lì il mar rosso
ma è solo lì dopo questo errore molto
lungo dalla cartina non si vede bene ma
lì sono 300 chilometri che il nilo si fa
tornando indietro 300 chilometri in
mezzo po se lo fa tornando indietro ma
lì che capisce dove voleva andare
no voglio andare nel mar rosso non
voglio andare neanche nell'atlantico io
voglio andare nel mar mediterraneo come
se avesse dovuto sbagliare strada per
capire qual era la sua strada
e a quel punto è convinto e non lo ferma
più nessuno il nilo passa attraverso 2
deserti una catena montuosa e arriva lì
nel mar mediterraneo dove darà vita a
una delle più grandi civiltà della
storia dell'uomo
ma perché vi ho parlato di fiumi non lo
so io farò 12 perché questa immagine
così potente no del nilo che fa tutta
questa strada che torna indietro lì ecco
guardatela bene questa è l'immagine di
come funziona ogni scoperta ogni nuova
invenzione tecnologica ogni nuova
creazione artistica ha dentro di sè
quello che si chiama piccolo grande ma
ce l'ha
coefficiente di serendipità che cos'è la
serendipità la serendipità è infortunato
incidente un errore casuale ma che ti
porta poi a scoprire qualcosa di nuovo
esempi colombo che prende va dritto no
cerca le indie e va a sbattere contro
l'america serendipità o albert einstein
che per settimane si arrovella sui suoi
fogli non riesce a trovare la formula è
poi un giorno finisce il suo turno
l'ufficio brevetti va a casa in tram il
tram si ferma e era stand è colpito da
dall orologio del campanile di berna lo
osserva gli viene lì il lampo e dice
aspetta aspetta ma se se questo tran
schizzasse alla velocità della luce
il tempo li dell'orologio del campanile
andrebbe avanti sempre la stessa
velocità per me e scopre la relatività
serendipità ma alziamo ancora di più
colombo einstein ancora di più
frank è persona
questa è la parte in cui fate grande
frank è per come dimenticarlo frank è
persone una sera andò a dormire ma
dimentica fuori dalla finestra il suo
bicchiere cola cola bibita la sua
abilità preferì preferita va bene poi si
sveglia al mattino c'erano meno 10 gradi
apri la finestra e inventò il ghiacciolo
primo ghiacciolo della storia ma dai
ancora di più colombo einstein il
ghiacciolo il viagra
il viagra anche il viagra è stato
invitato per sbaglio la pfizer stava
mettendo appunto no questo farmaco
contro l'angina pectoris sono ministro
ad alcuni pazienti come si fa in questi
casi non per testarlo i pazienti non
guarirono dall angina pectoris ma ebbero
comunque delle interessanti reazioni
fisiologiche che colpirono gli
scienziati della pfizer
qual è la morale di questa storia del
nilo dei fiumi colombo einstein eccetera
col quale la morale che non puoi
scoprire niente di nuovo se non sei
disposto a uscire dal tracciato
se non sei disposto anche ad andare
fuori dai margini e a pensare anche in
modo fuori dai margini pensare diverso
il pensiero divergente ogni nuova
scoperta si basa proprio su questo e
allora questa immagine ci fa una domanda
difficile adesso è però ineludibile non
possiamo eludere questa domanda la
domanda è nel nostro sistema scolastico
quanto spazio c'è per chi ha il coraggio
di andare fuori per chi ha il coraggio
di essere diverso di pensare divergente
quanto spazio c'è io ho trascorso due
terzi della mia vita a scuola tredici
anni come studente 15 come insegnante e
a questa domanda
sento adesso di poter dare una risposta
poco molto poco spazio a chi pensa
diverso nella nostra scuola
ma questo poco spazio ti prepara davvero
al mondo che troverai là fuori che
questa è una domanda importante
la risposta non è così scontata è perché
fino a qualche anno fa si si era un
sistema che aveva delle falle ma
funzionava tue entravi a scuola sei anni
ne uscì via 19 e più o meno ti sapevi
barcamenare nel mondo perché a scuola la
scuola un po te le aveva insegnato ma
adesso cos'è cambiato
adesso c'è qualcosa di nuovo
vi faccio un esempio per capirci io ho
fatto la prima elementare nel 1983 e
sono uscito dalle scuole superiori fatto
la maturità nel 1996 in questo arco di
tempo
quanto è cambiato il mondo si è cambiato
un po ma non tanto vero non così tanto
avevo ancora la certezza di trovare la
fuori quello che avevo visto entrando
per la prima volta male e sochi
all'esercizio mentale più difficile
siamo nel 2020 no dovete fare 2020 meno
13 andare al 2007 e di se vi ricordate
anche voi come me li porterò dattili nel
2007 cioè quanto era diverso il 2007 che
sembra vero una prova empirica e non è
niente ma una prova empirica però
con nome vale io nel 2007 avevo ancora
il nokia 3310 e la cosa bella è che l'ho
lasciato acceso nel cassetto e ancora
due tacche di batteria grazie quindi
cosa succede cosa cambia adesso cambia
che circa il 40 per cento dei lavori che
ci saranno nel 2033 quando usciranno da
scuola i bimbi che entrano quest'anno
per la prima volta a scuola oggi neanche
esistono quei lavori li neanche sappiamo
che cosa ci sarà come fai a preparare no
qualcuno verso qualcosa che neanche sai
che cosa sarà due c'è un altro problema
ci sono sempre più mestieri professioni
lavori che le macchine gli algoritmi
sanno fare al posto nostro molto meglio
di noi
un solo esempio hanno appena messo a
punto in america un algoritmo
un'applicazione che sa correggere i
compiti in classe cioè i temi non i test
pellicole croce i temi e lo sa fare bene
quanto l'uomo io verrà licenziato da un
algoritmo quale l'unica salvezza in un
mondo in cui tutto diventa automatico e
dove le macchine ti possono sorpassare
da destra e portarti via il posto come
fai a salvarti in un mondo così tenendo
sempre vivo e più a lungo possibile
il tuo lato umano imprevedibile il tuo
lato che ti fa fare così e andare verso
l'atlantico per dribblare puoi trovare
la tua strada e andare verso il mar
mediterraneo
tutto ciò che la nostra parte creativa
ecco come funziona ecco come ce la fai
ecco come li freghi solo così ora ti
faccio vedere un'altra cosa
un grafico che vedete rappresenta un
livello minimo e un livello massimo di
qualcosa a metà
c'è la media ocse cioè il livello medio
è una rilevazione fatta
tra i paesi ocse quindi i paesi
occidentali e vediamo dove l'italia in
questo bel grafico
finalmente siamo fra i primi in qualcosa
cioè dopo tutte le volte no che l'italia
sempre cenerentola no va bene vedere che
in qualcosa siamo fra i primi questo
grafico rappresenta l'indice di ansia
scolastica
siamo uno dei paesi fra i paesi
occidentali dove gli studenti provano
più ansia mentre sono a scuola
ora dobbiamo fare una cosa molto
difficile
chiunque vive nella scuola anche i
genitori pressi di tutti dobbiamo fare
una cosa molto saggia senza allarmismi
senza fare scandali ma guardarci negli
occhi e dircelo
i nostri ragazzi e le nostre ragazze a
scuola stanno male non stanno bene ed è
importantissimo che stiano bene perché
non impari niente se vive nella paura e
nell'ansia non puoi portare niente
dentro di te
se vivi costantemente nel terrore di
essere sbagliato del terrore del
giudizio dell'insegnante dei compagni di
deludere le aspettative dei genitori e
di chi ti vuole bene come fai
l'ansia è buona solo quando è episodica
allora si chiama ansia fisiologica e ed
è molto utile perché ci dà forza c.da ci
sveglia i riflessi ci fa essere più
pronti quindi prima di una prova prima
di un esame prima di una uno spettacolo
teatrale di una gara ma quando da
episodica diventa costante sia blocca
tutto
l'ok a tutto ed è come essere
costantemente col freno a mano tirato e
non riuscire andare alla velocità che
vorresti e allora io qui oggi con voi
non vi ho portato un progetto non vi ho
portato una fondazione io molto
umilmente vengo qua vi porta solo
un'idea
un'idea ed è questo
l'idea di scuola che io voglio
immaginare per il presente e per il
futuro
io ero un pessimo insegnante all'inizio
a io ero proprio quel tipo di insegnante
che esigeva che gli studenti
rispondessero quello che io sapevo già
che lo studente bravo per me era quello
che eseguiva i compiti no scuola del
passato ecco adesso anche grazie a quei
momenti li epifanici no ho capito che no
non funziona così e che la scuola che
immagino e cerco di mettere in pratica è
una scuola dove lo studente bravo non è
quello che ripete quello che tu hai
detto no non è quello che ti dà risposte
che tutti aspetti no lo studente bravo è
quello che ti sa fare le domande
lo studente bravo non è quello che
ripete a macchinetta quello che c'è nel
libro ma quello che ti sa dire cosa
pensa a lui di quello che c'è scritto
non è quello che sa stare sempre in tema
perfetto dentro il tracciato no ma
quello che sa qualcosa di interessante
da dire quello che lo sa dire bene ciò
che ha da dire di interessante lo
studente bravo e anche quello che non è
lì per le interrogazioni non è una
scuola dove si fanno interrogazioni ma è
una scuola dove ci si pongono
interrogativi dove per esempio non è
importante cioè no faccio un esempio a
caso la forma attiva e la forma passiva
del verbo punto no ma ti chiedi io in
cosa sono attivo e in cosa sono passivo
nella mia vita lo studente che sa
pensare diverso e lo studente migliore
che c'è e questa la scuola che sony una
scuola che si è fatta esattamente come
come questo disegno qua e quindi quello
che vi portano ideativi porto è un
domani che comincia già adesso in cui lo
studente bravo della classe e quello che
se gli chiedi qual è il contrario di
luce lui ti risponde spenda
grazie